mais d'abord le jour 2 de cette nouvelle
campagne après le nord emmanuel macron
était en alsace et marine le pen devant
la presse sans grâce à coeur de ville en
ville au pas de course emmanuel macron
bat la campagne de cet entre deux tours
sans relâche avant de se rendre à
strasbourg pour un meeting en plein air
sur l'europe le président candidat
commence son déplacement dans le grand
test par un bain de foule à la rencontre
des personnels soignants à mulhouse
ville symbole de la crise qu vide on est
tous les moyens dessus et de soigner les
gens dans le respect il souffre le
problème
[Musique]
emmanuel macron promet de remédier
alizés l'hôpital et défend son bilan
l'hôpital on à revaloriser les salaires
entre 183 à 400 euros par mois
c'est du jamais vu dans le sport c'est
que jamais bull s'étaient même pas ce
qui était défendu six mois plus tôt
alors qu'on a fait ça
emmanuel macron adressé un nouveau tacle
à sa concurrente dans cet
entre-deux-tours en l'accusant de
vouloir quitter l'europe sans plus oser
le dire le duel à distance se poursuit
dans l'eure à vernon marine le pen donne
une conférence de presse pour parler
démocratie et se dit favorable à un
septennat non renouvelables et à l'
usage du référendum
mon intention est donc de mettre fin au
monopole d'une oligarchie qui s'arrogent
le droit de décider au nom du peuple les
électeurs disposeront des moyens de
faire prévaloir leur volonté sur celles
des élus rendre leur pays aux français
c'est aussi leur rendre leur pouvoir
d'adopter ou de rejeter les textes votés
par leurs représentants comme emmanuel
macron marine le pen en quête des voix
des électeurs de gauche a prôné une
nouvelle fois son projet social avec le
maintien de la retraite à 62 ans
qui donne le tempo de ce début de
campagne on en débat tout de suite avec
mes invités avec serge herman bonsoir
présidente du cercle de réflexion france
audacieuse mathieu sous pierre bonsoir
mathieu fin bienvenue à vous aussi
essayiste auteur avec damien fleurot 2
2022 la flambée populis est publié chez
plon et on peut dire qu'il ya une
flambée populiste pour ce premier tour
pour revenir pablo pino livia bonsoir
bienvenue responsable éditorial de la
revue regards elle est ici avec ruth pas
et les tarifs précis bonsoir laetitia à
chaque journée son match en quelque
sorte c'est ça une campagne de de second
tour et même macron en alsace on l'a vu
qui parle notamment des carabistouilles
que son adversaire sur l'europe et puis
marine le pen qui donne cette conférence
de presse sur les institutions alex est
alors son d'ambiance et de marine le pen
alexeï guerman qui pour vous a marqué
les esprits aujourd'hui
écoutez je trouve que c'est pour
l'instant c'est trop tôt pour pouvoir
dire réellement parce qu'on a deux
styles de campagne totalement différent
on a un président candidat qui rentre
dans l'arène en donnant avec toujours le
l'emphase qu'on lui connaît
qui donne tout parce qu'il a très peu de
temps pour un match qui est quand même
qui s'annonce plus que serré plus que
dangereux on a une marine le pen qui
déroule sa campagne de façon
très cadrée et mine de rien est toujours
de façon très ronde sans sans rupture et
en arrivant à maintenir le cap tout en
allant sur des sujets qui sont des
sujets qui parlent aux français allez
aujourd'hui à vernon sur la démocratie
c'est une façon pour elle qui est
détournée d'arriver à parler de son
référendum y compris avec la question de
la préférence nationale s'en aller
franco sur la question de la préférence
nationale non plus donc
une thématique toujours plus générale
après ce que je trouve très intéressant
dans la façon dont emmanuel macron
démarre cette campagne c'est qu'en fait
il va vraiment au contact et qu'on a là
des moments alors que pour le premier
tour on se souvient des débats figé
orchestrée qui ne correspondaient pas ce
qu'attendait forcément les français et
là ça donne lieu y compris à des images
qui sont des images parfois un peu
mais à hauteur de ce qui t'a lecteurs
mathieu soupire c'est intéressant si on
compare les entrée en campagne parce que
c'est un match retour en quelque sorte à
2017 et 2022 moi j'ai un peu le
sentiment qu'elles sont à fronts
renversés ou en d kalck si on se
souvient d'une entrée en campagne d'
emmanuel macron il ya cinq ans un peu un
peu tranquille comme ça et peut-être
trop tranquille alors il y a de cela il
ya une semaine encore une fois on se
plaignait d'avoir une élection
présidentielle sans campagne sans débat
sans enjeu et même sans suspense en fait
on est passé dans un autre dans un autre
monde en quelques jours la campagne est
là et on a deux flux on a deux quasiment
belligérants fait on voit bien que que
le ton monte et le ton monte parce que
les enjeux sont là et que le suspense en
réalité est là même si on a pour
l'instant aucun sondage qui ne donne
marine le pen à l'elysée on voit bien
que tous les sondages nous disent que il
y a un écart qui s'est réduit
considérablement c'est même tout le
paradoxe en fait de cette élection on a
un emmanuel a conquis a élargi sa base
au premier tour il est vrai mieux qu' il
est rendu à l'envi les revenants et il
est en quelque sorte un un survivant
parce que il est encore là et il fait
mieux qu il y a cinq ans mais au
deuxième tour s'il a réussi à élargir sa
base au premier tour on voit bien que
d'après les sondages sa base en revanche
de deuxième tour s'est considérablement
rétrécie sa capacité de rassemblement
n'est plus du tout la même qu'il ya cinq
ans et pas totalement illogique il est
le sortant donc déjà avoir un match
retour avoir une revanche c'est quelque
chose d'inédit depuis giscard mitterrand
on n'a pas eu de match retour parce que
en général l'opinion veut de la
nouveauté donc l'opinion change en
général au moins les deux finalistes là
on a un match retour et c'est d'autant
plus étonnant que encore une fois
emmanuel macron en tant que président
sortant a été quand même plutôt essoré
par un quinquennat difficile en tout cas
ça a été une succession de crises qui
aurait dû l'essorer et qui
paradoxalement l'on a un peu sauvé mais
marine le pen elle-même a en fait subi
un quinquennat un peu difficile on se
souvient que depuis 2017 c'était une
sorte de course d'obstacles de 2017 à
2019 souvenons nous que marine le pen et
10 points en dessous de son étiage
habituel qu'elle ne se remet en selle
qu'à la faveur du mouvement des gilet
jaune et que en dépit de cela le rn
passe à côté de toutes les élections
intermédiaires
donc on n'imaginait pas qu'elle était en
dynamique on n'imaginait pas non plus qu
emmanuel da cruz est maintenant là
comptent plus m et pourtant ils sont là
et au coude à coude alors par faire
l'analyse du premier tour sur l'anneau
qui fait dès dimanche soir hier aussi
mais c'est vrai que c'est intéressant de
se dire que ce qui avait imprimé pour
marine le pen l'opinion le débat
entre les deux tours ou pour jean luc
mélenchon cette sortie lors de la
perquisition au siège de son parti
finalement ça a été en partie gommée par
le par le temps puisqu'ils ont l'un et
l'autre fait des scores très très très
élevé dans l'opinion mais je voudrais
pas lancer ce thème là pablo depuis ovi
vient sur un emmanuel macron ont
finalement on a l'impression qu'ils
retrouvent un exercice qui lui convient
pas mal voilà depuis deux jours c'est
parce qu'il ya à nouveau un enjeu enfin
je partage de ce qui a été dit juste
avant c'est à dire que pendant le
prologue pour la campagne du premier
tour il y avait absolument aucun enjeu
ou plutôt c'était comme ça que la macro
ni avait considéré le premier tour c'est
l'inconnu d'asson il serait au second là
tout d'un coup les sondages comme le
disait mathieu bains sont ils sont au
coude à coude donc il rentre en campagne
après ce que je trouve intéressant et
c'est et c'est là qu'il ya une
différence et je suis complètement
d'accord avec ce que vous dites et
alexandra tout à l'heure vous allez dire
à l'essai à pardon alexia avec ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure en fait le
marine le pen n'a pas besoin en fait de
deux d'utiliser le vocabulaire de
l'extrême droite pour faire comprendre
qu'elle est d'être un droit tout le
monde sait très bien qu'avec d'extrême
droite tout le monde connaît son projet
phare je veux dire il est ancré dans une
histoire qui est très forte et que les
français et les françaises connaissent
alors qu emmanuel macron lui c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué nous on a
beaucoup plus de mal en fait à
identifier ce que c'est que son projet
d'autant plus qu' il est un peu obligé
de changer son fusil d épaule par
rapport on va dire à la façon dont il a
exercé le pouvoir pendant cinq ans dans
la mesure où sa réserve de voix
potentielles le ce qui va lui permettre
en fait de ré accéder à la présidence de
la république c'est précisément les voix
de gauche donc là il est un peu en train
de louvoyer moi ce que je constate
depuis depuis hier c'est que gray milla
il en train de changer d'avis sur sera à
peu près tous les sujets alors la
retraite à 65 ans maintenant c'est à 64
mais peut-être et puis finalement il
voudra bien modules et c'est pas un
changement radical bouger c'est un tout
petit bougé mais enfin il met de l'eau
dans son vin j'ai pas avec la
possibilité de passer par un référendum
d'ailleurs c'est sur le thème de notre
notion des votes j'ai peur en fait qu'on
perde de vue en fait qu'on perde de vue
qui en fait le projet le prêtre du
projet d' emmanuel macron c'est que on
arrive toujours pas très bien en
dessiner les contours alors regardez
cette campagne au premier tour ben c'est
au deuxième qui va commencer mais je dis
pas que ce soit peut-être un peu trop
tard un peu court et on y reviendra
évidemment il faudrait qu'on se
concentre un peu sur cette entrée en
campagne de marine le pen laetitia ce
qui est intéressant c'est vraiment on
l'a un peu évoquée mais elle est là le
mot clé c'est peut-être l'apaisement la
candidate de l'apaisement oui c'est un
cerveau qui est revenue d'ailleurs dans
la bouche de ses lieutenants en fait si
vous voulez on est dans la dernière
étape de ce que l'on a tous commenté
pendant des années ce processus de
dédiabolisation de normalisation est
bien là thomas nous sommes à la dernière
étape et donc c'est une nouvelle marine
le pen rassurante apaisante douce qui se
montre avec ses chats jeudi chat
pourquoi parce qu'à l'intérieur de son
groupe de son équipe on a même théorisé
la stratégie du mia ou alors la
fondation jean jaurès a donné un autre
nom la stratégie du moelleux donc c'est
vraiment cette impression là on est dans
l'émotion on est peut-être dans un
deuxième tour me semble-t-il où
l'émotion va être la plus importante et
donc le rn ne lésine pas sur les
symboles je ne sais pas si vous avez vu
la dernière affiche voilà voire aux deux
tours on va l'avoir et c'est vrai que
mon la voix bras ouverts dans la posture
du président emmanuel macron sans aucune
mention ni de son nom ni de son prénom
d'habitude on avait on avance avec eux
le pen était abandonnée mais il y avait
marre il n'y a plus rien maintenant donc
on est dans la suite logique de celle la
fiche de la rentrée rappelez vous une
marine le pen bucolique un peu qui
souriait béatement regardant le ciel sur
ce fond vert liberté chérie dont vous
voyez ci n'est pas nouveau c'est à dire
qu'elles se sont pas dit entre les deux
tours on va complètement changer l'image
c'est juste la suite et la fin et c'est
quoi l'objectif faire oublier tous les
traits caractéristiques et l'histoire du
front national puis du rassemblement
national bien sûr les dérapages du père
mais aussi la radicalité et des mesures
de son programme de son programme de
2022 la violence des mots finalement
marine le pen mise tout sur cette
stratégie du miiaou est donc ses
lieutenants vous avez raison thomas sont
là pour le rappeler et pour marteler on
va les entendre ces mots pendant quinze
jours donc autant s'y habituer tout de
suite ce matin c'était par exemple
sébastien chenu sur rtl
les français voudraient et veulent je
crois un chef de l'état qui soit
bienveillant attentif respectueux si
tous ces français pensent que ils
peuvent se rassembler autour d'une
candidate qui les protège et bien alors
ils sont les bienvenus plutôt que de
repartir avec ce candidat de la
brutalité voilà vous voyez la stratégie
allez assez simple à comprendre il
inverse totalement le système de valeur
c'est à dire que celui qui est brutal
violent qui dynamitent la société ce
n'est pas le front national ce n'est pas
le rassemblement national ce n'est pas
marine le pen mais c'est emmanuel macron
prix est donc cet inversement et cette
mécanique comme ça à verse il faut quand
même l'a martelé pour qu'elle rendrait
pour qu'elle soit acceptée par l'opinion
publique donc jordan bardella on mettait
lui aussi une couche sur france 5 fois
je dis à tous les français qui ne
veulent pas de cette purge sociale qui
veulent de la protection qui veulent
tout simplement une société apaisée une
société de justice de faire le choix de
marine le pen on a vu ce qui émanait mac
on pouvait faire fait confiance à marine
le pen pour qu'elle puisse apaiser la
société française julien audy julien
odoul mais jordan bardella a dit
exactement la même chose et c'est vrai
que dimanche soir julien au double qui
étaient sur le bateau de france info a
carrément répété cinq fois thomas on
peut les compter le slogan de fabien
roussel marine le pen promettra des
jours heureux donc c'est un grand écart
qui frôle le claquage la question c'est
est ce que finalement même si on voit
ces grosses ficelles savez efficace et
cette image d'une marine le pen
apaisante va imprimer l'opinion publique
ou est ce que quand ces gros si gros que
finalement on a du mal à l'accepter on a
déjà un élément de réponse vous en faite
ça marche parce que effectivement c'est
un narratif qui l'ont essayé d'imposer
depuis déjà un moment en fait marine le
pen elle n'est pas entrée en campagne
cette semaine elle est entrée en
campagne à un an et demi ou à peu près
donc tous ces traits d'image elle les a
travaillé depuis longtemps et les
enquêtes de ce point de vue là sont tout
à fait claires elle a gagné la bataille
de l'image toutes les enquêtes le
démontrent elle est en haut des
popularité des personnalités politiques
préférées des français elle ne fait plus
peur et on va même que dans les enquêtes
d'opinion en fait le rejet des manuels
macron désormais atteint un niveau
équivalent au rejet que pouvait susciter
marine le pen antérieurement sur le
saint père il va pas faire que ça mais
c'est moi c'est ce qui m'a frappé dans
la conférence de presse cet après-midi
le sourire omniprésent oui oui on voit
bien que c'est aussi la femme qui montre
qu'elle a changé de toute façon il ya
une chose qui est certaine c'est
qu'aujourd'hui marine le pen a démontré
sa capacité de résilience mais je crois
que pour bien analyser complètement il
faut aussi dire qu'au premier tour cette
image cette affiche avec femme d'état
visait aussi à réparer la question de
l'incompétence qui avait été quand même
extrêmement présents tôt lors du second
tour et il est fort à parier qu'en même
que les équipes d' emmanuel macron iront
sujet par sujet essayer d'aller taper
sur la question de la crédibilité bien
sûr du programme de marine le pen et de
sa capacité elle même à être une femme
d'état d'eau qu'elles s'offrent le luxe
au second tour d'aller sur les questions
de l'apaisement parce qu'elle a traité
le sujet de la crédibilité
avec cette première séquence au premier
tour et cette affiche femmes dessin vous
dites c'est ces théories 061 par les
spécialistes de la communication ça
s'appelle l'enjeu de les toffes qui aura
les toffes du président de la présidente
de la république et ça se joue aussi à
ça un vote de second tour est ce que
emmanuel macron est plus capable de
gouverner est la france que marine le
pen et c'est la vraie question que se
posent les français ça fait lien
on peut même se dire que plus en plus
l'élection présidentielle dans cette
cinquième république se joue là dessus
et peut-être de moins en moins sur les
programmes en tout cas ce sera l'un des
enjeux programme contre programme
mathieu se veut un complément en fait on
voit que la place de la radicalité dans
cette campagne n'est plus du tout la
même qu'en 2017 en 2017 il y avait une
très forte demande de radicalité que
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon dans
des registres évidemment différent
arrivé à capter cette fois ci c'est eric
zemmour qui à l'automne a tenté de
capter cette demande de radicalité il y
est parfaitement parvenus pendant
quelques temps mais ça a montré ses
limites et est désormais plus personne
ne revendique en réalité la radicalité
tout le monde joue la carte de la paix y
compris évidemment marine le pen car
pour devenir président il faut
rassembler mais alors marine le pen qui
est qui a réagi à cette formule martelée
par jean luc mélenchon dimanche soir à
quatre reprises pas une voix pour madame
le pen la candidate du rn lui reproche
de trahir ses électeurs écouter marine
le pen le comportement de jean luc
mélenchon a été pour moi une source de
grand étonnement pour parce que tout
simplement parce qu'il a été plus du
plus dur il ya cinq ans face à un
emmanuel mâcon virtuel qu'il ne l'a été
en réalité dimanche soir face à un
emmanuel macron réels c'est à dire après
cinq ans de démonstration par emmanuel
macron une politique violemment anti
sociales et bien il a été plus proche
des manuels mâcon dimanche soir qu'il ya
cinq ans eh bien ça je pense que c'est
une c'est une trahison quand même de sa
part de ces secteurs oui parce que oui
parce que ses électeurs ils attendent la
protection
pablo et puis vient la protection c'est
intéressant parce que c'est finalement
le mot qu'emploie marine le pen pour
caractériser le vote mélenchon c'est un
peu court c'est un peu court mais c'est
une dimension non c'est peut-être une
dimension mais je pense que c'est très
rapidement brossé de la part de marine
le pen mais juste
la différence en fait entre 2017 et 2022
par rapport au discours de jean luc
mélenchon sait que en 2017 marine le pen
n'était pas aux portes du pouvoir il n'y
avait pas d'enjeu c'est à dire que
effectivement une abstention et
d'ailleurs ça va être le cas encore
aujourd'hui 1 en 2010 est lorsqu on
s'abstenait et qu on ne votait pas
emmanuel macron on n'imaginait pas
marine le pen arrivait au pouvoir là
lorsqu'on va s'abstenir il ya là cette
potentialité l'a donc évidemment
discours de jean-luc mélenchon il a il a
changé après juste revenir par rapport à
ce que vous disiez moi je pense qu'il
faut pas non plus prendre les français
pour des idiots cela parce que marine le
pen parle de chats et médée veste rose
que les français imaginent que elle est
devenue hyper sympa il perd -2 même si
j'entends un que c'est la stratégie des
cadres du r'n que aidés de la
communication du r'n essayé de faire
passer ça les gens connaissent très bien
le programme de marine le pen et je
pense que lorsqu'ils votent pour marine
le pen il vote en conscience et ils
votent à c'est à bord alors ils votent
alors il ya deux choses c'est parce que
je pense que là precious et qui vote en
conscience et la deuxième chose c'est
que je pense que ces caractéristiques en
fait d'une premier tour de cette
élection présidentielle et ça va
peut-être être aussi pour le second tour
c'est c'est le rejet en fait ils votent
par rj est à dire qu'ils n'en peuvent
plus des manuels macron et donc du coup
il se précipite en fait sur bas ce qu'il
leur semble être l'alternative crédible
en chèques la petite réflexion qui
l'accompagnent parce qu'elle a changé et
donc ce qu'on sait sur saïd et les
enquêtes démontrent bien que en matière
de traits d'image marine le pen a
considérablement lissée les choses elle
n'incarne plus du tout elles n'inspirent
plus du tout la même peur qu'il ya cinq
ans ce serait un homme et son projet de
société les gens les gens savent
toujours qu'il est basé quand même sur
la xénophobie et l'islamophobie alors
partie mis en sourdine oui alors
justement genre ça nous amène la
transition plus sur ce que vous évoquez
tout à l'heure donc cette conférence de
presse sur les institutions ce
référendum pour faire entrer le le
principe de de préférence ou de
priorités nationales dans la
constitution ainsi que la primauté du
droit français sur le droit
international il ya aussi cette
dimension alexa germond c'est quoi une
conséquence d'une telle réforme si on
essaie de comprendre ce qui pourrait se
passer c'est une vraie révision
constitutionnelle un éloignement de
l'europe on pense à ce qui s'est passé
en pologne sur la primauté du droit
polonais sur le droit européen bref ça
il ya tout ça et ça renvoie à ce que
disait justement pour le coup le
président candidat
sur les carabistouilles sur l'europe
parce que évidemment mise à part la
question de la xénophobie et de
l'islamophobie dans le dans le programme
de marine le pen que certains contestent
d'ailleurs mais ce qui est évident c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est à mon sens
dirimant c'est la position par rapport à
l'europe et les positions économiques
qui mettrait vraiment la france dans des
positions extrêmement compliqué y
compris y compris sur l'ensemble des
marchés bon donc une fois qu'on a posés
çà elle revient sur la partie
démocratique avec très curieusement elle
réattaque beaucoup moins sur la partie
proportionnelle qui est pourtant il
traditionnellement le cheval de bataille
et qu'il a à sa conférence de presse
c'est parce qu'elle met prioritairement
aujourd'hui elle raccroche ce que vous
disiez très justement quand elle a
réémergé elle a réémergé au milieu des
gilet jaune et donc elle raccroche sur
une thématique qui est l'utilisation du
référendum et en donnant même dans la
façon dont elles expriment les choses
une un poids plus fort au référendum en
dix ans et de cette façon là vous pouvez
bloquer ce que potentiellement
l'assemblée pourrait être amené à vous
proposer donc on voit bien qu'on est
dans des logiques institutionnelles et
constitutionnelles qui sont très
curieuse parce que ce sont des outils à
disposition constitutionnelle qui n'ont
pas la même valeur qui n'ont pas la même
ce que sa licence des lecteurs cd
thématique peut-être certaines on est
loin du film art d'achat n'est la
réalité pour voilà la réalité pour
répondre très précisément à votre
question thomas c'est que en abordant
les questions de préférence nationale en
abordant les questions de d'éloignement
finalement l'europe
elle donne deux signaux le premier c'est
moi avec un référendum j'évoquerai et je
je prendrai en compte le sens du vote
contrairement à ce qui s'était passé
2005 donc là leur boucle la boucle et le
second point c'est que c'est une façon
détournée de mettre une très grande
distance avec ce qui fait les valeurs
cardinales finalement de l'europe et ça
je pense qu'aujourd'hui dans la
stratégie on n'y est pas arrivé encore
parce que la campagne de second tour
arrive mais emmanuel macron devrait
théoriquement quand même allé taper fort
pour exprimer en quoi on met de la
distance parce que c'est vraiment deux
projets qui pour le coup sont distincts
de ce point de vue là il y en a un qui
est pleinement européen et l'autre qui a
évidemment sans le dire parce
qu'autrement elle sait qu on ne votera
pas pour elle mais sans le dire elle met
une distance constitutionnel avec les
valeurs cardinales de l'europe ça qu'on
parle d'eux en tout cas ses adversaires
de phr exit caché l'europe ce sera le
thème de notre débat thématique qu'un
représentant des deux finalistes mais
demain tout à l'heure ce sera
les retraites au programme il ya un côté
ping pong mètres sous terre dans une
journée de campagne d'entre deux courses
certes marine le pen dans sa conférence
de presse évoquent l'hypothèse d'un
septennat non renouvelables comme le bon
temps
du présidentielle on va dire ça comme ça
et quelques minutes plus tard évidemment
parce que ils sont suivis d'un élu n'est
autre part par des journalistes et même
macron lui répond en disant septennat
pourquoi pas mais non renouvelables
c'est au peuple de trancher c'est on va
voir ça tous les jours quoi c'est un
ping pong terme alors encore une fois
c'est logique on est désormais en pleine
campagne par ailleurs on disait au début
qu'il était à fronts renversés sur la
forme ils sont aussi pour partie à
fronts renversés sur le fond c'est à
dire que marine le pen dans sa
conférence de presse du jour dénoncé les
dévoiements en fait de notre régime
démocratique du à la gouvernance des
manuels macron c'est un conte est
totalement à rebours de la menace qu'a
toujours incarné l'extrême droite sur la
question de l'état de droit donc c'est
assez baroque oui pourquoi est ce que ce
jeu de ping pong ou va probablement
durer jusqu'à la fin parce que encore
une fois le suspense est là et que
l'électorat et volatiles comme jamais on
le disait avant le premier tour et on a
pu le mesurer précisément à travers
l'écart qu'on a enregistré entre les
derniers sondages et les résultats
effectifs personne n'a dit que les
sondeurs s'étaient trompés parce que les
sondeurs ne se sont pas trompés les
sondeurs ont enregistré la température
jusqu'à jeudi ou vendredi et on a vu que
la température dimanche était différente
der que les sondages font partie
désormais intégrante de la campagne
présidentielle ils sont d'une certaine
façon un outil de pilotage de notre
propre citoyenneté c'est à dire que à la
fin on se détermine aussi non pas en
fonction de nos envies de nos humeurs de
nos intérêts mais en fonction d'un
contexte plus global je dirais que c'est
pour partie d'ailleurs un progrès en
réalité c'est à dire que menace qu'il ya
une manière et construisent aussi la
réalité politique donc là le biais le
biais des sondages dans la construction
la wii ça compense en réalité ils
électeurs on parle de d'électeurs
machiavel cr qui tient compte des
sondages en se disant
mais c'est pas mais c'est pas du tout du
machiavélisme je voudrais dire que le
vote utile est d'une certaine façon un
vote intelligent car il est un vote
recontextualiser c'est pas moi tout seul
qui danse dans l'isoloir encore une fois
me détermine en fonction de mes intérêts
de mes humeurs ou de mes envies ou de
mes goûts je le fais en fonction d'un
contexte qui me dépasse et hommage que
le contexte soit parfois réduits aux
sondages ou louis hanks et plein
d'autres choses par exemple la situation
géopolitique internationale par exemple
le cours du pétrole
mais précisément ça se voit dans les
sondages et c'est ce qui a permis de
mesurer que par exemple le contexte
international avait définitivement
disqualifié un eric zemmour et que le
vote utile a pu jouer y compris à
l'extrême droite donc tous adorent tout
à fait intéressant les dix ans titre
landais mou du jour c'est
carabistouilles laëtitia s'est passé par
emmanuel macron ils sortent comme ça
régulièrement des mots un peu un peu
alambiqué un peu ancien peut alors ça
s'appelle de la communication oui
politique vous êtes là pour parler
carabistouilles ce n'est pas je me suis
renseigné avant de venir sur le plateau
ce n'est pas dans l'habitude emmanuel
macron en privé de l'utiliser donc quand
on utilise un mot qui n'est pas qu'il
fait pas partie de son vocabulaire
tarabiscotée ça veut dire qu'il ya un
objectif l'objectif il est simple et qu'
on en parle sur un plateau de fer
populaire parce que carabistouilles
c'est de l'arrco tous qui finit en eau
et en général c'est plutôt de larbaud ça
bien du belge et ça veut dire balivernes
et donc il le sait très bien emmanuel
macron qu en utilisant carabistouilles
ça le fait descendre un tout petit peu
son piédestal le président des riches
et beaucoup de gens qui utilisent le
terme
c'est bien désuet pas non plus être vous
savez ça mieux que moi peut-être mathieu
complètement étranger à son style donc
il faut trouver des choses qui font
populaire dans son style est donc avis
tout c'est un mot je ne dis pas qu'il a
écrit juste avant mais si vous voulez
c'est dans son logiciel de président
candidat mais ça annonce aussi et c'est
pour ça que je les choisis parmi les
mots du jour c'est ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure ça annonce l'une des
stratégies de même à croquer des
débusquer les balivernes où les
mensonges de élégante pour dire mensonge
mais voilà et derrière on peut imaginer
qu'il y aura l'ensemble des troupes qui
vont aller pour le coup points 1 point
pour expliquer en quoi c'est un mensonge
donc vous avez beau élégant en eau et la
colonne vertébrale
ces nouveautés de conrad ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure sur le ping pong
c'est nouveau en fait que la chef de
l'état sortant où on va dire le patron
d'un grand parti de la droite
traditionnelle
mais en fait tu répondes points un point
haut à l'extrême droite enfin génère ce
n'était pas le cas en 2017 était encore
moins le cas en 2002 en 2002 et même en
2017 s'était à nouveau barrage
républicain front républicain de façon
on n'a pas à vous parler oui pas eu de
débat d'entre deux tours souvenons-nous
ans en 2002 exactement jacques chirac
l'avait refusée catégoriquement et en
2017 en vérité lorsque vous écoutez j'ai
réécouté il ya une semaine le débat
d'entre deux tours entre emmanuel macron
et marine le pen ils se répondent à
peine c'est à dire que emmanuel macron
en fait déroule son projet est en phase
marine le pen est de trouver des angles
pour l'attaqué et puis elle n'y arrive
pas tellement mais il n'y a pas deux il
n'y a pas de dialogue là comme vous
l'avez dit comme vous l'avez de noter
assez justement comme on l'a tous notés
'aaa' c'est justement autour de cette
table ils se répondent c'est à dire
qu'elle 17 tena non non
edwidge ah bah oui finalement peut-être
il a raison mais quand même renault sas
et je pense que c'est un fait politique
important qui marque la banalisation de
cette extrême droite que pourtant on
avait on a essayé et on devrait toujours
essayé de
mettre en dehors du jeu l'analyse à sion
qui se lit à travers encore une fois les
intentions de vote dont elle bénéficie
c'est aussi ça qui change pour que ils
sont désormais au coude à coude donc on
ne peut pas traiter par le mépris un
adversaire qui se situe quasiment à son
programme forcément du verbe et je ne
pense pas qu'il faille n'est prise et
l'électorat ni d'ailleurs mais brisée à
marine le pen tout court par contre ne
pas répondre en fait à ce qu'elle
propose est attaquée non pas sur le
septennat parce que je vois pas
tellement l'intérêt de dialoguer avec
marine le pen sur la question du
septennat mais surtout ce qui est
problématique racistes xénophobes
islamophobes homophobes et sexistes dans
son programme là je pense que la russie
et l'ukraine enfin il y en a des sujets
de discussion et de divergence est l'un
des événements de cette
deuxième journée de campagne d'entre
deux tours c'est le ralliement de
nicolas sarkozy emmanuel macron steve
jourdain doit être juste là en coulisses
derrière le rideau bonsoir steve nicolas
sarkozy qui a donc brisé le silence ce
mardi nicolas sarkozy qui sort enfin du
bois on le sait valérie pécresse a
longtemps attendu son soutien sans
surprise c'est finalement emmanuel
macron qui reçoit donc le soutien
officiel de l'ancien président nicolas
sarkozy il a officialisé son soutien
dans un texte publié sur sa page
facebook ce mardi je voterai pour
emmanuel macron parce que je crois qu'il
a l'expérience nécessaire phase une
grave crise internationale plus complexe
que jamais parce que son projet
économique mais la valorisation du
travail au sens de toutes ces priorités
parce que son engagement européen est
clair et sans ambiguïté voilà ce que dit
nicolas sarkozy s'est donc plus sain
qu'un simple barrage à marine le pen
c'est un soutien une forme d'alesio à
emmanuel macron reste à voir si des
choses ont été négociés ou pas en
coulisses entre emmanuel macron et
nicolas sarkozy on parle notamment de la
création d'une future majorité pour les
élections législatives du mois de juin
très au sénat c'est précisément cette
idée d'une éventuelle future coalition
qui fait bondir certains des patrons de
la droite tard oui beaucoup de réactions
à cette annonce à cette adhésion de
nicolas sarkozy à emmanuel macron tenez
prenez gérard larcher il annoncé hier
qu'il voterait à titre personnel pour
emmanuel macron qu'à première vue ans il
est sur la même ligne que nicolas
sarkozy mais on va voir ce tweet qu'il a
publiée aujourd'hui en réaction aux
petits textes de l'ancien chef de l'état
l'opposition ne peut être réduite à une
confrontation entre majorité
présidentielle les partis extrêmes
sous-entendu non à la création d'une
grande majorité avec les maquereaux nice
non à la mort du parti l air en quelque
sorte et puis autre réaction celle du
patron du groupe lr bruno retailleau sur
twitter également bruno retailleau lui a
annoncé qu'il voterait blanc qui ne
voterai donc pas pour emmanuel macron et
il met aussi en garde il dit que le
choix de nicolas sarkozy est une
position personnelle que ce choix n'est
pas la position de sa famille politique
ne construirons pas ne reconstruirons
pas à la droite en ou diluant dans le
maquereau nisme voilà ce qu'écrit bruno
retailleau ce mardi ce qu'on constate
ici au sénat c'est la quasi unanimité
des sénateurs aient l'air contre cette
idée d'un partenariat à venir avec la
macro ni écoutés nous devons faire échec
à marine le pen en mettant même si c'est
une décision difficile un bulletin
macron dans l'urne mais ce vote ne peut
en aucun cas de mon point de vue et là
je me sépare de nicolas sarkozy est rare
aliments nous ne sommes pas encore une
fois fongible dans ma chronique je pense
qu'il a été beaucoup trop loin dans son
appel ce matin et que ça ne reflète pas
la ligne d'une autre parti politique on
s'est un peu compliqué mais en résumé le
groupe ait l'air au sénat c'est une
consigne de vote unique de ligne
politique quand on vote du second tour
blanc ou emmanuel macron ma nouvelle ère
c'est aussi une promesse vous l'avez
entendu la promesse de ne pas entrer
dans une éventuelle grande coalition
avec les maquereaux nice en tout cas
pour le moment thomas merci steve pour
cette analyse l'ex légèrement le
ralliement de nicolas sarkozy est ce que
c'est forcément une bonne nouvelle pour
emmanuel macron qu'est ce qui pèse
aujourd'hui l'ancien chef de l'état dans
l'électorat de droite je crois que dans
votre question il ya deux points en fait
le premier point vous parlez de
ralliement
il me semble que c'est un peu tôt en
fait pour pouvoir vraiment parler de
ralliement parce que aujourd'hui le
tweet qui a été publié c'est un soutien
on n'attendait pas autre chose de sa
part contre marine le pen et emmanuel
macron c'est très fin mais effectivement
il ne dit pas je vote emmanuel macron
pour faire barrage à marine le pen ça va
au delà non il dit que c'est le seul
aujourd'hui qui est en état d'abord qui
a un projet européen travail etc donc il
est déjà sur ce positionnement là
les naissains valérie pécresse et nos
miss alors ça ça c'est le soutien
attendu qui n'est pas venu pour sa
propre famille là on pourrait beaucoup
comme ben oui mais donc c'est pour ça
que je parle de ralliement le crès de la
mort ce de ralliement on a bien compris
que tourner dans un mouvement qui a
commencé avant le premier tour c'est un
peu trop tôt parce que dire qu'il est
fongible dans le maquereau nisme je
pense que c'est mal connaître à ce
moment là nicolas sarkozy c'est dire que
on se dit vraiment est ce que d'abord
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il pèse quand
même ça c'est l'autre aspect de la
question voilà qu'elle convienne
division comme on pourrait dire
également et puis surtout c'est sûr on
aura la réponse véritablement à cette
question lors du troisième tour
présidentiel c'est à dire les
législatives et là aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas fait d'avoir même si c'est une une
volonté manifestement d'emmanuel macron
d'aller une sorte de maison commune
encore plus étendue
je ne suis pas certaine que ça soit
d'ailleurs ce qu'attend d'eux les
français forcément travailler sur la
question de la coalition avec des
sensibilités différentes et arriver à aa
additionnés et finalement à compléter si
on écoute ce qu'a dit le président de la
république dimanche soir il a parlé de
compléter son projet complété son projet
c'est pas faire un projet unique sous le
même toit
c'est c'est à ce moment là quelque chose
qui est plus dans l'ouverture et pour
l'instant il me semble que nous n'avons
pas encore la réponse
réelle à nicolas sarkozy il est un peu
plus qu'un soutien emmanuel macron et se
murmure dans les couloirs du pouvoir que
il est en train de discuter avec lui des
arrangements pour les législatives on
vous laisse tant à l air mais là même
nous laisse autant de sièges que vous
voyez ça va ça va beaucoup plus loin à
nicholas et en définit des
circonscriptions dans lesquelles il y
aurait un candidat
tout sans le dire on
s'abstient se présente pas pour que l
air soit gagne ou lrm et nicolas sarkozy
est en train avec emmanuel macron
apparemment de calculer tout ça mais il
faut rajouter et je me tenais juste à
luzech il faut rajouter quand même qui
aura françois bayroux au milieu suit va
pas se laisser faire edward fils edouard
philippe au milieu aussi avec horizon
qui est quand même très imprimé en
termes de sièges de nombre de sièges les
républicains sont quand même beaucoup
plus puissant que le modem même s'ils
sont encore là où que l'on aille à agir
horizons en tout cas il y aura plus de
gens aujourd'hui à replacer mais
s'est pas fait et on a bien vu que au
sénat en tout cas ça que ça coince sur
cet aspect là je vous propose d'écouter
la réaction des manèges macron sur ce
soutien je ne vais pas redire rallye nom
de nicolas sarkozy
je le remercie de sa confiance et le son
soutien je pense que c'est très
important et que salam au nord et ça
m'oblige et donc je pense qu'il faut
rassembler très largement et j'ai
entendu sur les sujets de travail de sur
les sujets de travail sur les sujets
d'europe ils se retrouvent et pablo pino
vivien je disais est ce que c'est
forcément une bonne nouvelle parce que
si l'objectif de nicolas sarkozy c'est
d'aller chercher plutôt les modèles
macro
forcément des manades vacances est
d'aller chercher les électeurs de jean
luc mélenchon suis pas sûr que le
soutien de nicolas sarkozy soit la
meilleure carte ou la carte maîtresse
dans son jeu non je suis tout à fait
d'accord et mais de toutes les façons
enfin là ce dont on parle c'est pas un
revirement s'est pas et on découvre pas
aujourd'hui que emmanuel macron a fait
une politique de droite et que ben ils
en train d'attirer il en train d'aspirer
une partie des cadres des dlr dont un
cadre éminent comme nicolas sarkozy
effectivement mais moi je pense
effectivement que c'est juste une
question de en fait nicolas sarkozy en
train d'acheter lrm il arrivait il dit
voilà moi j'arrive avec je ne sais pas
moi à 25 50 70 députés qui vont équipe à
se faire réélire ce qu'il ya cette
question c'est à dire que emmanuel
macron il a été ré il a été élu en 2017
et ensuite il a eu une majorité très
confortable à l'assemblée nationale même
plus que confortable là il n'est pas du
tout dit que s'il est réélu il puisse
avoir la même assise en fait à
l'assemblée nationale donc il va avoir
besoin nécessairement de composer pour
créer une majorité à l'assemblée
nationale pour pouvoir faire passer ses
réformes et c'est à ce moment là que
nicolas sarkozy entre en jeu parce qu'il
a quand même vous avez tout à l'heure
alexia vous vous posiez la question de
savoir ce qu'ils faisaient il a quand
même un sacré réseau et notamment un
réseau de parlementaires qui peuvent
être très utiles pour la constitution de
cette majorité présidentielle c'est ce
qui est assez quand même intéressant sur
les stratégies parce que bon bah là il
ya ce soutien qui est majeure et qui
intervient tôt dans la campagne de
second tour al'inverse on a une marine
le pen qui apparaît seul et qui ne
surtout pas donner le sentiment de
négocier avec un eric zemmour avec ou
avec d'autres les futurs postes de son
un éventuel gouvernement ou même à une
alliance en vue des législatives c'est
vraiment d'une strate y avait
différentes avec d'autres ça pourrait
peut-être l'intéressé avec d'autres
sheller ça aurait peut-être pu
l'intéressé pour la stasi qui a
récemment adhéré avec eric zemmour c'est
forcément beaucoup plus compliqué
absolument pas elle doit se tenir à
cette distance d'eric zemmour si elle
veut rassembler un peu au deuxième tour
non à la limite je mets de côté les
questions tactiques qui pousse toujours
à intervenir dans les discussions qu'un
nicolas sarkozy nous avec l'entourage du
président de la république je mets ça de
côté en été je reviens à la question de
fond pendant très longtemps la ligne
c'est l anémie chiraquienne qui
consistait effectivement entretenir un
cordon sanitaire entre la droite et
l'extrême droite est d'ailleurs son
discours son dernier discours de
président pardon de vous interrompre il
ressort régulièrement
dans les médias sociaux et aujourd'hui
on l'a vu de nouveau beaucoup circulé où
il rappelle 7,7 d'higuain franchissez la
ligne aulas avait fixé un cap pendant
très longtemps et puis ce cap avait été
remis en cause par qui en fait par
nicolas sarkozy qui avait introduit la
notion du ni-ni précisément et c'est
nicolas sarkozy qui avait fixé ce cap
pendant très longtemps alors à un moment
où l'extrême droite était sans doute
moins menaçante qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui mais c'était ça la ligne et
donc c'est bien nicolas sarkozy qui pour
partie là dans un contexte très
particulier réenclenche une forme de
front républicain et à un moment qui
n'est pas anodin l'extrême droite est
haute mais deux c'est le moment où
compte tenu de la droitisation de
l'opinion et de l'extrême droite isation
d'une partie de la droite c'est le
moment où la porosité et très grande
entre encore une fois une partie des
sympathisants et l'air et une partie des
sympathisants du rassemblement national
donc c'est très important de le faire
maintenant alignés c'est quand même un
message envoyé à la droite qui compte
donc bien sûr que emmanuel macron ne
peut pas son compte ne peut pas s'en
contenter puisque les réserves de voix
vont être à gauche et donc rapidement
c'est à la gauche qu'il va devoir se se
s'adresser mais ça compte en fait ce que
fait nicolas sarkozy dans le complexe
les voix discordantes elles ne sont pas
si nombreuses que cela en réalité les
éléments langage des républicains sont
les mêmes que les éléments de langage
mélenchonistes pas une voix pour marine
le pen c'est pas rien c'est vrai que
c'est pas rien il était
emmanuel macron à mulhouse et strasbourg
aujourd'hui sont deux villes où jean luc
mélenchon est arrivé en tête dimanche
avec autour environ 36% des des voix il
a d'ailleurs été interpellés
pratiquement partout et c'est sans doute
ce qu'il cherchait aussi sur les
questions sociales pablo pino vivien cet
électorat de jean luc mélenchon on le
voit ce quand on fait des projections
alors c'est en fonction des instituts
entre 30 et 40% vers emmanuel macron
entre 20 et 30% vers marine le pen est
sans doute entre 40 et 50% ça dépend des
instituts encore une fois l'abstention
comment vous analysez vous ces
ce report de voix et peut-être co4
conscience qui se pose à moi déjà je
dois dire que j'ai jamais rencontré et
je traîne beaucoup avec des insoumis
rejet beaucoup d'insoumis autour de moi
je n'ai jamais rencontré un seul qui
raboter marine le pen au second tour
alors je pense et donc ils sont pas
forcément dans le noyau dur en fait des
insoumises c'est peut-être des électeurs
je ne nie pas leur existence mais je ne
les connais pas en revanche la majorité
des gens que je rencontre chez les
insoumis évidemment et effectivement ils
iront plutôt s'abstenir moi c'est pas
mon cas enfin moi j'irai voter emmanuel
macron sans réfléchir en bouche emmené
tout ce que vous voulez mais j'irai
voter mâcon le problème en fait lorsque
j'essaye en fait d'argumenter et leur
dire bah non il faudrait aller voter
emmanuel macron c'est que il me ce sont
des gens qui suivent la politique qui
ont suivi ce qui s'est passé pendant ces
cinq ans qui sont engagés sur des causes
qui sont engagés sur la question sur la
question des libertés publiques qui sont
engagés sur la question de l'immigration
de la lutte contre le racisme etc et là
c'est vrai que le constat il est assez
affligeant en fait du point de vue du
pouvoir c'est à dire que lorsque je
parle aux gens à la cimade ou à la croix
rouge qui sont mi temps à la croix rouge
et qui me disent bah oui mais bon ça
fait cinq ans la police l acer les
tentes ils volent les chaussures des des
migrants pour pas qu'ils reviennent ils
coupent l'eau dans les dates dans les
dents dans l'est dans les camps de dans
les camps de migrants comment vous et
que ces gens là à et votez pour emmanuel
macron c'est très difficile c'est
aujourd'hui public là qui va aller voter
ni pour l'un ni pour l'autre par exemple
certainement vous ne les fréquente est
pas mais c'est vraiment les classes
populaires qui va passer de qui vont
passer de jean luc mélenchon à marine le
pen c'est c'était le justement ce qu'on
avait vu cette jonction des pôles chez
les jaunes arrivent chez les gosses
comme mathieu un mot et ensuite on parle
d'écologie en conclusion je sais vous
voulez intervenir c'est un des pièges en
fait dans lesquelles s'est mis pour
partie emmanuel macron star que la
campagne s'est joué à droite et même
très à droite parce que emmanuel macron
lui-même a mis le curseur à droite parce
que encore une fois eric zemmour a
existé que l'extrême droite a été haute
comme jamais parce que la primaire d
elle et à elle même s'est joué sur une
ligne de droite donc ces problèmes en
une des campagnes présidentielles qui
s'est le plus jouer à droite et en dépit
de saintes le candidat de la gauche est
à un cheveu en fait de la qualification
parce que la gauche s'est unifiée parce
qu'en réalité chez les électrices et
électeurs chez les élections ouais mais
chez les électeurs il n'y a donc pas de
gauches irréconciliables et donc du coup
le candidat de la gauche le mieux placé
est passé à un cheveu la qualification
est donc le deuxième tour alors que
toute la campagne depuis des mois se
jouent à droite et même très à droite le
deuxième tour se joue à gauche et donc
c'est toute la difficulté des dalles
mates que de réussir remuscler désormais
sa jambe gauche qui est singulièrement
atrophiée 420 mille voix un tout petit
peu plus d'écart entre jean luc
mélenchon et marine le pen je rappelle
cet écart comme vous dites à un cheveu
et pourtant il est plus beau joueur
qu'il ya cinq ans où les cas les plus
marquées
l'écologie pour terminer il nous reste
allez on va prendre deux trois minutes
parce que ça peut être un enjeu en tout
cas dans la stratégie d' emmanuel macron
de cet entre deux tours il a un bilan
contrasté à la fois il a fait voter des
lois la loi à gec anti-gaspillage pour
l'économie circulaire où la loi climat
et résidences et puis en même temps
l'état français s'est fait condamner
pour une action climatique pendant son
quinquennat donc le bilan il est
contrasté est ce qu'il ya un électorat
écologiste à aller chercher comme
beaucoup voter jean luc mélenchon qui a
beaucoup voté et jean luc mélenchon et
je ne suis pas certaine que dans tous
les électeurs qui sont allés vers
yannick jadot il ya aussi cette
séparation avec sandrine rousseau donc
on voit bien que alors que la campagne
va se gagner sur la gauche je crois que
emmanuel manque on aurait intérêt à
mettre en avant des sujets sur lesquels
il peut y avoir justement des additions
positive des compléments sur son sur son
programme et notamment il ya deux points
il ya la jeunesse et ya l'écologie et je
remarque ça n'a pas beaucoup été
souligné me semble imanche soir mais que
dans son discours il a évoqué la
question de la planification écologique
et ça c'est un référentiel qui est
mélenchonisme accepter et assumer donc
c'est une main tendue et je crois que ce
sera jeudi de mémoire qu'il aura un
déplacement sur l'écologie et ce sera
extrêmement intéressant de voir de
quelle façon il va ouvrir mais en
faisant à ce moment-là peut-être des
propositions complémentaires qui soit
une main tendue ça va être difficile ça
va peut-être difficile est le champion
du climat il a juste interdit les
pouilles et en plastique en cinq ans
c'est caricatural
mais encore faut-il années sur des
sujets sur lesquels il ya des choses à
construire pour le bien commun et qui
sont pas forcément parce que si on les
retraites il faut soit 65 ou 64 je suis
pas persuadé que ça fera venir des
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon bleus
faut pas sous-estimer quand même
l'impact des lois dont dont j'ai parlé
sur le milieu économique les entreprises
qui sont obligés petite avance sur leurs
gènes changer le climat est moins fort
oui mais certainement
sauter en réalité alors c'est vrai que
le plan de relance et de transition
alitée ou fait la part belle à des
financements de politiques énergétiques
environnementales ira donc en fait il y
a des choses
le problème des massacres on sait que ce
qu'on retient quand même c'est le modèle
amish et le raté de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat donc c'est ça
qui reste dans le vent et donc on ne
perçoit pas emmanuel macron comme un ami
de l'écologie et et c'est d'autant plus
important et mais il a une vraie carte à
jouer parce que précisément son
électorat à lui même son électorat lui
ne se désintéresse pas de l'écologie
fait contrairement à l'électorat de
marine le pen et à l'électorat d'eric
zemmour qui se contre moque de
l'écologie mais cela pour le hockey et
de souligner qu'il est en miroir avec
ses engagements rappelez vous ce qu'il
avait dit quand donald trump est sortie
de l'accord de paris et ce tweet avait
été mais cannes planète goasguen avait
été repris elle y avait vraiment
vraiment servir d'étendard et puis après
il y a les deux échecs que vous citez
est donc là c'est fatal merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat